venons en maintenant à nos carnets de
campagne voyons avec marie-pierre court
tellement ce qu'il faut retenir de ces
dernières 24 heures dans la campagne
présidentielle selon un sondage réalisé
par l'ifop nicolas sarkozy l'emporterait
au second tour de l'élection
présidentielle avec 52 % des intentions
de vote contre 48 % pour ségolène royal
dans la salle il était installé comme
pour assister à une pièce de théâtre
l'histoire commence peut être d'ailleurs
par un conte de fées un peu mièvre la
végétation est ainsi le relais
indispensable entre l'atmosphère et les
réserves d'eau du sol profond
mais sur la scène hier soir à nantes
c'est d'une tragédie annoncée dont leur
a parlé nicolas hulot économique
personne ne peut avoir une image de ce
que sera ce scénario de la fin du 21e
siècle mais il sera sombre ira ira pas
en campagne le suspense demeure jusqu'au
22 janvier ce jour là c'est promis il
donnera sa décision
nuit d'ivresse tu nuis de promesses sont
toutes les latitudes
l'année 2007 avait commencé dans un feu
d'artifice
ce matin à matignon pour la cérémonie
des voeux à la presse l'ambiance était
disons un peu plus coincé
dans les semaines à venir j'aurai à
coeur de partager mon expérience
de tirer les leçons de ce qui marche en
france et de ce qui ne marche pas je le
ferai avec mes convictions pour faire
gagner la france
et dans un sondage à paraître jeudi dans
paris match c'est nicolas sarkozy qui
tient la corde devant ségolène royal si
tous les deux parvenait au second tour
il y a deux mois c'était le contraire
mais la surprise du jour vient de
françois bayroux qui devance jean marie
le pen de deux points c'est une première
voilà qui ne devrait pas calmer les
ardeurs d'olivier besancenot en multi
n'y hier soir en normandie avec en prime
le droit de grève en moins ça c'est
sarkozy qui promet avec en prime les
retraites allongée ça aussi c'est promis
lui promet à ses électeurs
l'interdiction de licencier quand on
vous parlait il y a deux minutes de
conte de fées